happy roasts everyone look at this
beautiful crowd tonight we honor the
reason the world has a Vin Diesel Bruce
is a real man's man he told me numerous
times not to hold back tonight it's been
great getting to know you and your
lovely family and I see uh I met rumor
your daughter hi rumor I guess that's
the name your mom gives you when she's
not a hundred percent sure who your
father is get a shot of that whole table
it's the beautiful circle of life Bruce
your family looks like all the villains
you killed off in the die hard movies
[Applause]
what a legend Bruce Willis has been
fighting terrorists since before they
were Arab Bruce Willis is pro-gun Pro
flag and propecia Bruce Willis you love
your country so much he once said that
if the people wanted it he might even
run for president someday I'd make fun
of you for having political aspirations
but the last time I did that the
actually became president
all night people are saying I look like
you but symbol Shepard looks like Bruce
Jenner Willis
[Applause]
and lil rel little rel looks like Bruce
what you talking about Willis the Bruce
Willis you my friend are a total
original how is it possible to look like
a Nazi and a Holocaust victim he look
like Sir Patrick Stewart if he operated
a ferris wheel
how the are you a movie star you
look like a bouncer at a nursing home
you're like Elmer Fudd if he hunting bad
scribbs instead of a scallywag 'it's
this guy Bruce Willis wants an
Oscar so bad he's slowly
morphing into one it's crazy he went
from being Hollywood's leading man to
Demi Moore looking at you and saying you
know what I'd rather the dumb guy
from dude where's my car but Bruce we
all wish you luck with your lawsuit
against the Blue Man Group this is so
much fun I mean Bruce is such a star
you've been in some of the most iconic
scenes in cinema history my favorite
scene in Pulp Fiction when you save the
guy from getting in the ass hey
Dennis at that point in the movie were
you like wait who's the bad guy again
[Applause]
of course your most recent film was a
big bomb death wish what a
stinker Bruce it looked like you did
your own stunts and your own lighting
editing and directing OOP how about a
hand for tonight's host Joseph
gordon-levitt
JGL Joseph gordon-levitt the only three
words more boring than gluten-free
cracker
thanks for dressing up Joseph you look
like a lesbian on the way to prom
[Applause]
yeah Joseph started in third Rock from
the Sun and Dennis Rodman smoked three
rocks in front of his son yeah why not
give it up for our next Secretary of
State my man Dennis Rodman
you think kim janghoon is a nice guy and
he thinks you're Scottie Pippen
my pal lil rel is here so happy for you
buddy so happy Congrats on all your
success and your newest film Angry Birds
too good to see you're not selling out
what are you playing Jim Crow
[Applause]
great to see Cybill Shepherd again and
just like most shepherds Sybil hasn't
worked much in the last two centuries
Sybil had an affair with Elvis how cool
man
years after their affair symbol revealed
that Elvis went down on you is that true
yeah all right
you think a hound dog would have a
better sense of smell
and speaking of moonlighting da Moreira
had to cancel two shifts at macaroni
grill to meet here da Moreira is what
you look like right before you say
tomorrow I'm starting their juice
cleanse kevin pollak I love you man but
that Christopher Walken impression is so
old Ashton Kutcher tried to marry it
love you Kevin
sit tight you're gonna be big whenever
Paul Giamatti dies Bruce yes you've
accomplished so much buddy but I think
it will always be your blockbuster
Armageddon that serves as the greatest
metaphor for your career because in the
end you got destroyed by the rock us
Jersey boys a race to have thick skin so
I knew you'd be a great sport tonight
and I wish you continued success good
health and I can't wait to see your next
project die hard six natural causes
[Applause]
[Music]